Frank this is your first film as writer
and director why did you see sighs a
step into the director's seat now and
how is the experience in a few there was
an opportunity to do it and I thought I
think most actors will want to do it
once get out of their system and once
you're in you're in you know and it was
it was hard work but I enjoyed it I
think directing is about delegating I
think it's all about I had a brilliant
cinematographer and a really good crew
around him
and the backup team and I had a great
cast I was very lucky I pulled in a lot
of favors I'm out of Fighters with all
my friends now it'll you know but I was
lucky and to have sort of the quality of
talent you know people like Exeter did
me a favor and came in for a dying Nick
Moran did and got Charles dance which
was unbelievable
that was quite surreal oppositely as of
Parliament thinking what am I going to
say it says dance
Cayley how is it you see your character
Peck and princess were there anybody you
were basing it on in particular did you
draw inspiration from anywhere yeah
there's actually our two people that was
based on and I think I'm I grew up in
the area so for me it was it was very
close to home and I kind of knew exactly
who this girl was and so having two
people in mind that was like okay she's
definitely like a combination of these
two girls so then it was quite easy just
being immersed in that culture I know
that clearly had grown up on the same
mistake I did in South London and I
thought because it was really important
that someone got that accent which is
quite Pacific that's all part of South
London
yeah so I said that you actually said
that something new first read the script
you know I know this girl I thought you
would yeah I think it's really hard to
kind of know who that girl is from the
outside unless you kind of grew up in it
and kind of really know these girls and
grow with the me it's it's kind of
weird-looking sort of in you did a
number of films have you found the
transition from modeling into acting
it's it's difficult it hasn't been an
easy transition and I didn't expect it
to be I think when I moved away and
started studying I was like this is
gonna be so hard
um but that's the whole point is the
challenge
part of it and kind of getting through
that and now I think you know it's got
easier I've started working so people
are like okay no she's acting she's not
just hanging out on a beach in LA what
does it give you the modeling didn't for
example does I think of you I think
there's a sort of self expression that
comes with acting and and you kind of
get to explore so many different
emotions that living through something
whereas modeling doesn't kind of have
that and I think for me I had like a a
persona whilst modeling that was just
kind of one thing
so with acting it's many notes I think
he's interested as well that the fact
that you didn't just fall outta bed one
morning so I want to be an actress I
mean when you sort of studying at the
stress box going in Los Angeles know
what straightaway all right okay that's
that's that's the right um that's a good
word they're here
you know because it's that sort of them
the start of acting that I've always
been into that the method II think sort
of goes back to the famous actor to
studio New York and sort of my heroes
growing up Steve McQueen and Paul Newman
and Brian up so soon as those strays
burger okay come on with those princess
your character in the film talks about
being tough to build a reputation you
know something you fighting to keep
isn't he how tough is it for both of you
to build that reputation and key for
reputation as an axe are now moving into
directing as well I think and it's
difficult sometimes it's I think it's
about what jobs not to do I think that's
the secret he does the other day it's no
it's nineteen eyes looking at it is
looking at the script and and I'm you
know not so though that and it's
difficult because especially in this
country where job in actors so his bills
to be paid so you have to work and it is
difficult sometimes but it is I think
that's the secret I've been quite lucky
out of sort of fallen on some good
scripts over the years but I think you
need a bit of luck as well anything like
yeah you definitely need luck I think
that's so important and it's it's really
hard to predict any sort of reputation
within the industry should we do a movie
and love the script and then went
and you're like oh god and then
sometimes the other way around like
people get involved in things and it's
terrible and said in the movies it's
like fantastic so it's kind of I think
hard to sort of keep hold of your own
reputation certain way it's difficult I
think sometimes you do get a feeling on
set you think that yeah I've got a good
feeling about it yeah the happy set
isn't only the sign of a good film and
again in the film Micky lives my code
and a mantra doesn't he do you guys have
one that unified I think the secret to
this industry is to take the work
seriously but not yourself I think that
that someone said that to me a long time
you know take the work seriously don't
take yourself seriously and I think if
you try and do that it's like a fable so
you know just try being just won't be a
nice person
yeah just trying to work at it no I
think that's that that's always a secret
I think for me I think there is a case
sometimes in this industry that people
take themselves more serious and they go
to work yeah I think so I think it's
about the work and just kind of focusing
on that and then everything else is
secondary to the work and it's putting
in the time and ensure you keep working
at the craft in getting better and the
other things we always enjoy it you know
it's not an easy industry yeah you've
got to enjoy it that's bad thing that
that helps as well it's to enjoy what
you do
you